[Music]
yes so today we're going to talk about
the Arctic Ocean and climb it and before
I get started we can just get situated
here a little bit and I'll tell you a
brief bit of my background to tell you
how I come how I came to be an ocean
physicist so I study the physics of the
oceans and in particular I study the
physics of the Arctic Ocean
so my background is in mathematics and
physics so here we are here in New Haven
where we hopefully we all know where
that is and we're today we're going to
talk about the Arctic Ocean that you can
see up there so how did I come to study
the Arctic Ocean maybe it started
because I grew up in the high north I
grew up in the high north in Canada in
the Yukon the Yukon is just east of
Alaska it's very cold up there it's dark
in the wintertime it's north of 60
degrees but it's just a little bit south
of the Arctic Circle which is 66 degrees
north so we would walk to school in the
wintertime and it was dark and when we
came home it was already dark again so
we didn't see the light in the
wintertime the summer time was amazing
because it was light all the time so you
could play outside at 11 o'clock at
night and it was like so so I grew up in
the Yukon until I was 15 years old and
then my parents sold all their
possessions and bought a boat and took
us sailing we lived on a boat with them
and we sailed around the world and a few
years later we ended up back in Canada
so this is maybe how I came to love the
oceans and the North when I was in
Canada I went to study physics because I
thought physics is as good as anything
to study and I kind of liked physics
when I was doing physics I did a senior
project where I was studying bubbles in
corn syrup because that relates to Meg
in volcanoes and I read a paper by this
professor and I thought this is really
exciting research and I'd like to
continue doing things like this and this
professor was at Cambridge University he
was over here in Cambridge Cambridge is
where Isaac Newton developed his theory
of gravity evidently motivated by an
apple that fell from a tree and hit him
on the head so there I studied fluid
mechanics and mathematics and the study
of fluid flows and there we have it and
this is what I do I study the Arctic
Ocean and how the Arctic flows how are
the Arctic Ocean flows and and moves
around the globe
okay so let's launch into the Arctic the
first thing we think of when we think
about the Arctic is of course sea ice
and here's a here's a picture of sea ice
here you can see covering the North Pole
does anybody so sea ice sea ice is when
the ocean freezes it's so cold up there
that the ocean freezes it's different
from the ice on Greenland and Antarctica
that's land ice and that that is when
you get snow that continually packs down
sea ice is when the ocean freezes
does anybody have a guess or or know
approximately how thick the sea ice is
guesses yeah if it guess over here how
many eight inches that's pretty good
eight inches any other guesses
okay that's close to eight inches yep
one yard did you say one yard you know
I'm afraid I grew up in Canada so I
don't know what a yard is but but I do
know that the Arctic sea ice is about as
tall as me it's about safe
well I'm not 2 meters but it's about 2
meters thick or or maybe 6 and a half
feet or so so that's how thick the
Arctic sea ice is it's not this massive
it's not really thin like eight inches
but it's not this you know tens of
meters thick lid so that's the Arctic
sea ice and it's a very it's very
dynamic it gets blown around by the
winds it's not just this sort of white
lid that sits there it gets blown around
by the winds and it melts and freezes
every season so I've got a little video
here that we can watch the sea ice has a
seasonal cycle in March every year it's
thickest and then it goes through you
can see the date up in the left corner
it goes through to its its smallest
extent and thinnest every September in
the summertime and every year the sea
ice follows the same this same cycle of
growing in the winter and then melting
after that in recent decades probably
many of you know we are losing sea ice
so the the extent of sea ice in the
Arctic is getting smaller and smaller
this is shown in this graph here this is
a graph of the extent of sea ice on the
on on this on this axis in millions of
square kilometers and that the x-axis is
a year starting from when we first had
satellite measurements in the late 1970s
so when we were first able to look down
on top of the globe and and figure out
how much sea ice was covering the North
Pole region and that
blue bar there is about the area of
Texas for reference the area of Texas is
less than a million square kilometers
it's about 700,000 square kilometers so
you can see this you can see this trend
in decline in Arctic sea ice we're
losing about 10% or a little more than
that sea ice per decade of sea ice per
decade
that's what climate scientists talk a
lot about but this um the right panel is
showing the sea ice extent last summer
when it was at its minimum compared to
the the pink line shows to what normal
conditions are in the Arctic so what
what does this mean and how does it
relate to global climate change and how
does it influence global climate change
in turn just to get oriented with that
I'm gonna show you I'm gonna show you a
movie here and what the movie is going
to show you down here you'll see a year
down here is the year and that's going
to move through and you can see this is
a map of the world and the movie tells
you where it's warmer than it used to be
in red colors and where it's cooler than
it used to be in blue colors okay so
it's the temperature difference relative
to some long-term average so let's watch
this movie starting in 1880 okay so blue
means it's relatively cool and these are
surface air temperatures around the
world and red means it's relatively
warmer than it used to be okay so now
we're in the nineteen fifties sixties
seventies eighties nineties 2000s and
this is where we end so the first thing
you notice is wow there's a lot of red
there right it's a lot warmer than it
used to be compared to some what we
consider a long term climate mean global
surface air temperatures are about a
degree warmer on average than they used
to be so there's two things you notice
here the first thing is well there's a
lot of red meaning it's a lot warmer but
there's a lot more red up in the polar
regions so the polar regions that we're
going to talk about today are warming at
twice the rate of anywhere on the globe
and just a brief deviation to climate
change and and and what this means where
we're putting these policies into effect
where we're basing these policies on
well we want to keep Earth's
temperatures below two degrees above
some historical value and and that's
great
but we have a point here where the
Arctic regions have long surpassed that
two degrees and we have no idea how
these Arctic regions are going to
respond to greenhouse gases that put the
global mean at two degrees okay maybe
that was a little bit complicated but
but in any case we're trying to figure
out what's going to happen in the future
we're trying to understand the climate
so we can make viable future projections
of climate so that we can plan for the
future in terms of adaptation and
policies to to reduce our influence on
the global climate okay so let's go to
the polar regions why is this why are
the polar regions warming more than
anywhere else on earth and a basic
answer to that is the sea ice is a
wonderful regulator for Earth's climate
because sea ice is highly reflective so
you know when you go outside on a really
snowy day like this winter and New Haven
we had a few and it was really sunny and
you go outside and it's
brighter then it would be if it was the
same sunny without the snow and that's
because snow and sea ice reflect back a
lot of light so about 80 percent of the
incoming solar rays that hit the sea ice
are reflected back to space so sea ice
keeps our earth cool and our climate
regulated once we'd lose sea ice then
the surrounding ocean and land can
absorb a lot more of that heat so this
is like a vicious cycle so we're losing
sea ice we're absorbing more heat that
heat is in turn melting sea ice we lose
more sea ice and this is the cycle that
we're going through now in technical
terms this is called ice albedo feedback
albedo means reflectivity so this is
this is what's basically what's going on
why the why the polar regions are
warming faster and one of the main
reasons why sea ice is so important for
our climate on earth so here's an aerial
view of Arctic sea ice this was taken by
a NASA plane that was flying about 1500
feet above the Arctic sea ice and you
can see when you look down on sea ice at
any time throughout the year it's not
just this vast expanse of boring white
it's full of of different sized chunks
and flows and and they're covered with
snow and they pile up on top of each
other and get blown around underneath
the sea ice you see any dark cracks
there that's the ocean and that's the
part that I study the ocean beneath the
sea ice and we study how the ocean
influences the sea ice cover and that's
what we're going to talk about for the
rest of the rest of this talk so let's
move to that dark bit the ocean below so
the ocean below the sea ice we said that
the sea ice was about six feet thick the
ocean below is about four kilometers or
two and a half
miles deep so if you're ever standing on
West Rock or East Rock looking across to
the other rock you can imagine that's
how deep the Arctic Ocean is below the
sea ice cover it's a huge body of water
or 37 football fields deep or if you
were to stack 10 Empire State buildings
on top of each other
that would be how far it is from the sea
ice to the bottom of the ocean so
there's a lot of things going on there
and a lot of things to study it's not
just this big gray body of water there's
a lot of interesting things in the
Arctic Ocean that can help us understand
how and why the sea ice is melting and
how how ocean ocean currents from around
the world are influencing the Arctic sea
ice so here's a picture of that what the
what the ocean looks like we have this
is just a just a schematic diagram where
the the red arrows indicate relatively
warm water and the blue arrows indicate
relatively cool water and over here is
that the North Atlantic here there's
Greenland here's Canada that's the
that's where I grew up right there
there's Alaska and and the Pacific Ocean
from the from the North Atlantic we have
relatively warm water warm and salty
water that moves up this is actually
part of the Gulf Stream so off our coast
here so the Gulf Stream moves up here it
circulates around the Arctic influenced
by the Earth's rotation influenced by
changes in seafloor topography like
mountains on the seafloor and influenced
by freezing and cooling on the surface
and also influenced by all these rivers
flowing in from from Canada Alaska
Siberia flowing all the way north and
spreading out over the Arctic Ocean and
then we have waters from the Pacific
Ocean that come in and flow around
and and interact with this with this
that waters from the Atlantic Ocean as
well so it's kind of a dynamic active
environment there's a random sneaker
that sneaker is not random um so I'm
gonna show you now a slice through the
Arctic Ocean you know when you go in and
you buy sneakers sometimes they're
really fancy ones I think these are like
Air Jordans or something and they have
you know they have it the sneaker cutout
so you can see what you're buying this
is this is what I'm gonna and they have
these different layers well the ocean if
you look at a slice through the ocean
it's equally as interesting well
arguably more interesting than that
sneaker um and if we we can't see it
because of course the ocean isn't
different colors but if we measure the
temperature and salt content which tell
us what the density of the water is we
can see all of these fascinating layered
structures in the ocean and that's what
a physical oceanographer just just
adores looking at maps that are these
cross-sections like that so here's what
a schematic cross-section of the Arctic
Ocean looks like so we have the surface
of the ocean here and this is this is
going down and getting deeper and we see
these different layers in the Arctic
Ocean the Arctic Ocean is as any ocean
is what we call stratified meaning the
dense waters on the bottom and the light
water is on the top so it's it's this
sort of layered ocean what happens in
the Arctic is the ice grows on the top
when it gets cold it freezes and when
the ocean freezes the salt is rejected
from the ocean and you get these sort of
dense briny plumes really salty parcels
of water that sink down and these salty
parcels of water sink down and flow in
to where they're where they're neutrally
buoyant where their density is the same
as their surroundings and this
sup this this complicated layered
structure in the Arctic Ocean if you go
if you go swimming here afternoon off
the coast here and in New Haven and you
and you swim down deep it gets colder
and colder right and you probably felt
you know when you go swimming in a lake
and you're in a lake in the summertime
beautiful Lake and up top your body up
top is really warm but then your toes
are kind of cold because they're in the
colder denser water that's like the cold
water is dense and the warmer water is
up here that's a stratified Lake the
Arctic is very different because as you
go deeper in the Arctic Ocean it gets
warmer so the cooler water is on the top
and the warm water is on the bottom well
that's different from you know in your
house in the let's say in the wintertime
sometimes it can be warmer upstairs
because all the warm air it's less dense
and it rises and the cool air is down is
down below so this is not what we're
used to but we have salt to help us out
here so because the deep waters are
saltier they're more dense than the
shallow waters this is a rather big deal
that as you go deeper in the Arctic
Ocean it gets warmer and this is what
we've spent our careers studying because
there's enough heat contained in these
warm deep layers that should that heat
somehow escape to the surface it would
entirely melt the Arctic sea ice pack so
we're trying to understand processes
that might influence the mix up of this
heat to the surface ultimately this warm
water derives from the Atlantic Ocean
where it's at the surface in the
Atlantic Ocean and then it goes down
deep into the Arctic Ocean so this is
kind of a big deal in in Arctic climate
okay so now we're gonna do a little
experiment and this experiment believe
it or not is this is a hint because I'm
gonna ask you to guess
things this experiment is related to
what we just talked about that Arctic
stratification okay and the idea is
we're gonna have two glasses we're gonna
have a glass and we can see them over
here we're gonna have a glass with fresh
water and a glass with salty water okay
those are our two those are our two
glasses on the far on the far end and
we're gonna put ice on top of each glass
okay so um I'd like to thank Libby and
Lucy for filling up the glasses for us
and they just filled them up hopefully
with the same temperature water right
both glasses in the same temperature
okay
you sure okay same temperature okay so
and now Libby can you please come up and
give us a hand here this is Libby Libby
is Libby is at Beecher Road school in
grade six if I remember correctly yep
and in in woodbridge and I know her very
well cuz she lives in my house so so
Thank You Libby
um and um what we're gonna do is we're
gonna put some ice oh no before we put
the ice in we're gonna put some salt
yeah see she's got the salt she
remembers what we're supposed to do um
we're gonna put some salt in one of the
glasses and and it's everyone's job here
to remember how much or not how much to
remember which glass the salt is and you
can put more yeah go for it okay perfect
so you can see it's very scientific than
measuring okay so now we've got um salt
in one glass and no salt in the other
glass and they're the same temperature
now we're gonna put some ice the same
amount of ice in each glass and then
we're going to ask you all to guess in
which glass will the ice melt first so
you're looking for the answer to in
which glass will the ice melt first
and yeah you can talk amongst yourselves
and come up with a theory here
well we'll wait
is it thoroughly dissolved
great okay
okay so how many should we put in each
ten okay and we have to put them in the
sink put three in each and then 3 and H
+ 3 in each yeah ok so ok everybody
ready
okay so Libby's gonna put um Libby's
gonna put nice in each glass and just be
very gentle when you put it in just so
we don't mix things up too much I'll
help you and you guys have to tell us
when we have about the right here's
here's an interesting question for you
well we have this up when sea ice melts
does the sea level rise no it doesn't
yes it does
okay how many think when sea ice melts
does sea level rise how many think sea
level rises when sea ice melts okay
and now how many okay mint and and I'll
guess the other ones okay so I'd say we
have about half half so the people who
just said when sea ice melts sea level
rises these people are going to be very
concerned as they're watching these
glasses that the water is gonna overflow
right are you gonna be very concerned
you are you're not so so maybe I'll let
you ponder that but that gives you a
little bit of intuition right that gives
you a little bit of into because sea ice
is floating on the surface of the ocean
okay
thank you very much Libby thank you okay
so now we have our two Gus um now let's
remember our question the the the glass
on the right has the salt in it in which
glass will the ice melt first who thinks
that the ice is going to melt first
in the glass on the right okay okay and
let's just do hands again who thinks the
eyes are gonna melt first with us on the
left okay very interesting so I'd like
somebody to of the first group who
picked the glass on the right that the
ice was gonna mount first there maybe
just tell me briefly what what your
intuition was why you thought that let's
pick some butt over there Sarah very
interesting yeah okay so so and maybe
many people were thinking like that you
put salt on your driveway so that you
don't slip on your driveway because it
melts the ice a little bit because the
freezing point of water with salt in it
is lower than zero degrees the freezing
point of freshwater so yeah thank you
Sarah that's an interesting observation
and I really liked the way you connected
it back at the beginning I said this is
related to this slide so so I liked that
you thought about how it might be
related I'm not going to tell you what
the answer is we're just gonna watch and
that will keep you occupied while I give
the rest of the talk so
that's gonna be way more interesting
than the rest of the time so so you can
just you can just watch and see what's
happening and and all and I'll stop part
way through sometimes it's really
helpful to visualize what's going on so
I'll stop part way through and put some
put some dye in there some food coloring
and we can see what's going on okay so
right so we said we said well this is
the picture of the Arctic Ocean
stratification but the question is well
how do we know that because if the
Arctic is covered with sea ice for most
of the year we certainly can't look down
and see what's happening by satellite
and then we could only see the surface
anyway we couldn't see the interior of
the ocean so so how do we know that this
is what the Arctic Ocean looks like well
way back in the old days people went out
and set up camps on these drifting ice
floes and they lived on these camps for
months and may measurements of the snow
depth on top of the sea ice how thick
the sea ice was measurements into the
wall into the ocean below atmospheric
temperatures and so on we have these
long-term records going back to the to
the early 1900's and the measurements
were sent back via radio so this was
really laborious and you needed to have
people living there on these camps the
other way you can go up and measure the
Arctic Ocean is by aircraft so you can
land a plane on the ice you have to make
sure it's springtime because springtime
is when you have enough light you can't
work in the winter with an aircraft
because it's always dark in the Arctic
it's the polar night and but but if you
did it in the summertime the ice might
be too sketchy to land on so you have to
do it when it's just the right amount of
light and just the right thickness of
sea ice this is an experiment that the
Navy funded back in the 1950s and the
scientists landed aircraft on the on the
sea ice and made a hole just like you do
when you're ice fishing made a hole and
put instrument
lowered them way down deep into the
Arctic Ocean they had some they had some
quite some interesting trials one of
their planes fell through the ice and
sank to the seafloor and they had to get
rescued and so on so that was all pretty
exciting and they were able to make
these maps you know that colored map
that I showed you with all the all the
arrows beautiful graphics they were able
to make maps just based on a handful of
measurements of what the structure or
the density of the Arctic Ocean
looked like they were able to make maps
that looked pretty close to the maps
that we make today about how the water
circulates in the Arctic Ocean well
today we have a much better way to get
measurements from the Arctic Ocean and
it's much better because in wintertime I
can sit here in my office over the
over-the-hill incline geology lab and
and look on my computer and see what's
happening at the bottom of the Arctic
Ocean I can have a nice warm coffee and
because now we do it it's all automated
and so I mean they're effectively robots
that are sampling the Arctic Ocean for
us and transmitting all of those data
because now we have satellites so we
don't have to use radios transmitting
all of the measurements from the Arctic
Ocean back to our computers so we can we
can look at them at our leisure and
these instruments can take measurements
in the harshest of arctic conditions so
here's just an example here here's the
ship that we were on this is a Canadian
Coast Guard icebreaker and and this
guy's waiting we've just put this buoy
in the water and he's waiting for the
helicopter to come and take him back to
the ship so we put these what they're
called ice based observatories we go up
there and put a bunch of sensors into
the sea ice and those sensors drift
around with the sea ice and return
measurements backed by a satellite they
measure atmospheric chemistry and snow
depth and sea ice thickness and also
this instrument here stretches way down
below the sea ice into that deep arctic
ocean measuring the properties of the
Arctic Ocean so
we can make those nice maps of that what
the layered structures look like in the
Arctic Ocean so this is this is what it
looks like this is called an ice
tethered profiler and it has a surface
buoy and this is the sea ice here and
below the sea ice is a long tether that
stretches way down you know to through
the depths of the Arctic arctic ocean
water column and it has on it a a
instrument that's that's about as tall
as me and it has a bunch of batteries in
it and it rolls up and down
automatically along this wire and
measures the temperature of the water
and the salt content of the water and
what depth it is and sends all the
measurements back via satellite to to
our labs and they can measure things
like ocean oxygen content and we can try
to understand things like ocean
acidification and measure other prop
other ocean properties oops so this is
what here's a little a little movie of
what it might look like if you're an
arctic scientist in the Arctic Ocean
there's lots of activity going on up
there there's lots of these these ever
these little these little yellow lines
are one of these guys these ice to there
profilers squirreling around getting
blown around by the wind on its ice floe
and returning all of the measurements
back to back to our labs so this is a
much more modern way to get data from
the Earth's system and earth scientists
are using these kinds of modern tools
all across all across Earth Sciences ok
now I think this is a great time to
pause and look at our experiment so if
you've been watching what what do we see
yeah
excellent great thank you for that yes
it is so the ice is melting relatively
faster in the fresh water cup we have to
remember which was the fresh water cup
right our fresh water cup oops
was this one and this was our salty
water Cup there's less ice in the fresh
water Cup then there isn't a salty Cup
well this doesn't bode well for our
theory based on putting salt on the
roads so oh and the other observation we
can make is the glasses didn't overflow
as the ice melted okay and you can think
about that later but based on Archimedes
principle when sea ice melts sea ice is
floating in the water when sea ice melts
sea level doesn't rise which is great if
you're in a cafe on a hot day waiting
for your friend so you can take a drink
of your drink it's not gonna overflow
okay so now I'm gonna put a little bit
of dye in each in each cup so we can
visualize what's going on hey that's
some diet it was beautiful look okay
that's some dye in the fresh cup this is
some dye in the salty code I put the
same amount of dye in each cup okay
certainly the fresh one is way more
interesting at this point okay so let's
think about let's forget about salt for
a minute and let's just think about
what's happening in the fresh cup as our
ice melts so we have a glass of water
and it's at room temperature and then we
put frozen water on the top of it the
water at room temperature is gonna start
melting our frozen water on the top and
when those Ice Cube's start melting the
water that they produce is cold and
dents colder and denser than the room
temperature water below so we get these
what we call plumes sinking down you see
if you always had some dye in your
pocket you would always know what was
happening in your drink and so so there
we go so that's what we're seeing these
beautiful plumes that are coming down
and when when the water sinks down when
it's melting it has to be replaced by
water that's flowing back up like this
so in that sense as the ice is melting
these coal plumes are sinking down and
this brings up warm water to further
melt the ice so it's kind of efficient
right and you your drink is cool you're
cooling your drink and at the same time
you're melting your ice that's what's
happening in the fresh glass in the
salty glass it's pretty boring okay I'm
gonna mix it up a little just just just
a little um you can see I did put dye in
there right okay I'm gonna mix it up
okay very different isn't it um by the
way if you ever have like birthday
parties or something you can make these
beautiful sunset drinks layered drinks
like this by having a sugary drink and
then ice on the top and you can put you
can put colors and but in any case
what's happening here what's happening
here is first of all we put the ice in
it's sitting in its bath of
room-temperature water and it starts to
melt a little bit and it melts and it
produces the same cold plumes that we
saw in the fresh glass and those cold
plumes there then more there then colder
than the water below so they want to
sink down they start sinking down up
they can't sink down because the water
below is so salty that it's more dense
than the cold plumes even though they're
cold they're not so dense that they can
escape through that salty layer
so that means that that ice is now
happily sitting in a bath of meltwater
unable to drag up all of the heat that's
available in the room temperature water
okay
so that's kind of the basic idea so the
reason why the ice melts slower in the
fresh glass has to do with
stratification it doesn't have to do
with the melting point of seawater or
the melting point of salty water or the
freezing point of salty water okay
so that's our that's our little
experiment and that's like the Arctic
Ocean there's heat down deep but the top
layers are so fresh that that heat has
no way to escape and melt the sea ice
now if there was some process like some
big storm activity or something that
came along and mixed up that
stratification like this and ruined the
the white backdrop then that ice now our
ice now because it's all mixed up is
going to melt faster so that that's kind
of the types of processes that we study
in the ocean okay where the spoon that I
was doing that's now the winds and the
tides big storms and stuff okay okay so
so we do have time for another
experiment and what we're gonna do is
say a few more words so I've told you
about the Arctic Ocean and about how sea
ice relates to global climate and how we
have to study the ocean because there's
heat in the ocean that can melt the sea
ice that influences global climate and
then I said how do we know there's heat
in the ocean well we went through and
figured out how we make measurements of
this and this is what we see in real
life so it's not that schematic anymore
but it is like the the sneaker
cut in half so this is a slice through
the Arctic Ocean a representative slice
through the Arctic Ocean depth here 0 to
250 meters
I believe the Empire State Building is
400 meters so this is like half an
Empire State Building deep and this is
the colors here are temperature and the
colors here are how much salt is in the
water so this is the surface of the
ocean and this is getting deeper and
what we can see that stands out are
these layers red is warm and blue is
cold so we see these layers of warm
water and these are the layers that
scientists have to monitor and
understand if we're to understand how
the ocean is influencing the sea ice
cover above and you can see that the
salinity just like our glass of water
over there before I mixed it up it was
fresh on the top with cold meltwater and
warm room-temperature saltier water
below okay so that's our layered
configuration in the Arctic Ocean I've
given you a lot of yes tobecome yeah so
we have these different layers so we see
cold water here and then a layer of warm
water here and then we get into a layer
of cool water and a layer of warm water
here it's it's a very complicated
temperature structure okay does anybody
else have any other questions okay so
what we're gonna do to give you some
intuition for these layers is we're
gonna finish off with a final experiment
we're gonna make our own layers okay
so we've already done that to a certain
extent with the with this but the ice
experiment but we're going to show you
another experiment now so this
experiment is not going to involve any
ice
it's not gonna involve ice and it's not
going to involve temperature at all so
all of the water that we're going to use
in this experiment is going to be the
same temperature and the only thing
that's going to change the density of
the water is the salt content okay
so what we're gonna do is Libby would
you like to help again
thank you okay okay so this is gonna be
this is this little this little vase
here that we have our Vaz is you can get
this at IKEA this is you know in the
section at the end but this is this is
just an Ikea vase it makes a great lab
tank okay so we're this is our Arctic
Ocean today this this little vase okay
so the first thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna take these two jugs of water
just our fresh water there's nothing
there's nothing different they're the
same temperature fresh water these two
jugs and then what Libby's gonna do is
she's gonna add a bunch of salt to this
one yeah just just very scientific just
dump it in that's pretty good so if you
do these experiments um for some reason
kosher salt isn't cloudy like some other
salt it's a cloudy and so you can't see
it as well so kosher salt is really good
because it's not cloudy then you can
stir it up mix it all up so this is
going to be our dense salty water yeah
and now we can have our Zen moment
watching somebody mix water
it's quite relaxing okay so what we're
gonna do this is going to be the water
that sits on the bottom this is the
salty water that sits down deep in the
ocean and I'm gonna take ya keep mixing
we we don't have to make it really clear
but just just we can just keep mixing
okay is that good okay okay now I'm
gonna take a little bit I'm gonna steal
a bit of the saltwater you'll see why
later okay great so now let's make this
our dense salty warm water and
throughout we know that warm is red so
why not put a few drops of warm in there
maybe three drops not too not too dense
or not too red let's see what that looks
like maybe one more drop two more cups
three workshops perfect great okay so
now let's pour that on the bottom of our
Arctic Ocean yeah go for it
yep you can pour all of it in there
so that water comes from the Atlantic
Ocean and it's warm and salty imagine
the Mediterranean where you have really
high evaporation like the Sun shines
down over a narrow Basin high
evaporation heating the water up making
it really warm and salty that water is
our Mediterranean water that ultimately
makes its way into the Arctic Ocean
but it's trapped at depth because it's
too salty to make its way to the surface
ok so now we've got that now our next oh
yeah our next thing that we want is our
fresh water ok and I'm gonna take a
little bit of that fresh water yeah
actually you can you can put a little
spoon take a little spoon I'll tell you
we'll tell you why we're doing this yeah
a little bit more perfect perfect ok
great thank you
so now we'll make our cold fresh water
we'll make it blue yeah just the same
like six or eight
okay let's see how dark it looks perfect
okay so now we've got a little sponge
here because we want to get this water
on top of this water without mixing it
up do you think we'll be able to do that
you do wow you have a lot of confidence
in us okay so we're gonna put that
little sponge there yeah we could do it
on this side okay so do you want to hold
the thing or do you want me to you'll
hold that okay can't hold it right over
the sponge and then move it up as I pour
okay
whoops you could follow this bunch
I'll follow you it's still going on the
sponge
this is your other Zen moment for the
day
is it working
sponge is sinking that's okay it's okay
it's okay we're good no no we're gonna
let this keep lifting up okay
it's still working sort of
I know I know we could we could improve
this by wetting our sponge with fresh
water first because do you know what
happened we had a dry sponge and we put
it right on the salt water so it's
soaked up the salt water and then it was
more dense but that's okay I think it
works great
okay can you pull it out great Thank You
Libby thank you okay so now we have our
warm dense water on the bottom yeah we
have our warm dense water on the bottom
and our cool light water on the top
remember they're the same temperatures
we're just calling them cool and and
warm just to relate it back to the
Arctic but we made the density by using
salt okay so now we have this layered
system and then we had this we had this
little little cup here where we put a
little bit of both the we put a little
bit of both the fresh and the salty in
this cup so let's put some some dye in
that what color should we use we could
use green okay so put some green in
there you can make yeah make it really
green just go crazy
let Lots yeah perfect
and then we can mix it up a little okay
and now we're gonna pour this in we
could pour half of it now just a little
just just to get a flavor for what's
gonna happen so now we're gonna you want
me to do it okay so now we're gonna pour
this in I'll just pour a little bit for
now and can you guess what's gonna
happen when we pour it in
do you think it'll mix it up I think you
think it'll mix it up okay yeah because
when you pour stuff it can be quite
energetic but let's let's take a look
okay so um so is everybody watching
really closely okay watch really closely
I'm gonna take a little bit of this
water and pour it in
[Music]
did you see it got trapped it got
trapped at the interface between the
between the fluids because the density
of this fluid is in the middle between
the density of the top fluid and the
bottom fluid because to make this we
took half of the top and half of the
bottom so when we put it in it plunged
down it brought a little bit of the
surrounding water with it and then it
kind of flowed out and and flowed into
its level of neutral buoyancy and that's
exactly what's happening in the layered
Arctic Ocean when sea ice grows in the
salty water forms and sinks down and
ultimately all of these motions and all
these these water processes prevent the
heat that's trapped at depth in the
Arctic Ocean from coming up to the top
lately we've seen regions in the Arctic
Ocean where this heat is more vulnerable
to escaping and we're seeing sea ice
loss as a result of that so these are
the types of processes we're studying so
I'm going to do one more I've still got
some of this left see you ready
you see that wave to the wave is really
slow if I were to tap the surface of
this water the waves are really fast
they're really fast because the density
of air is so much different from the
density of the water at the top surface
but the waves are really slow in the
middle because the densities are more
similar okay so I think I'll stop there
and if you have any questions we can
chat some more thank you
[Applause]
thank you for your help right back here
I think we on yeah so what's your
question so the question was if if they
if these freshwater the salt water acts
as a buffer between the fresh and the
salt what was the point of this bunch so
you hear that if the the salt water was
a buffer between the the fresh of the
salt what was the point of the sponge oh
well okay so the question was why did we
need the sponge because if the densities
are so different why couldn't we just
pour the fresh water on top of the salt
water well when you pour there's a
little bit of energy there the momentum
velocity and that can do mechanical
mixing and any cut like you saw when I
stirred with the spoon it it really
mixed up the two so we want to try to
prevent any kind of mechanical mixing
and the sponge was just sort of useful
because when you pour on top of a sponge
the water kind of spreads out through
the sponge and spreads over the surface
more rather than plunging in yeah more
questions yeah question I'm sorry we had
exactly yeah
exist yeah so what kind of fish live in
the Arctic water and how deep do they
exist fortunately I'm a physical
oceanographer which means that I don't
have to be an expert on the biology but
um but there are Arctic cod and new
species of fish that people are fish are
now taking pathways from the Pacific to
the Arctic Ocean that that they hadn't
been before because the region is
ice-free for longer there's like whales
and walruses and at the bottom of the
Arctic Ocean I was on a I was on an
expedition once and there was a National
Geographic team and they were looking
for a giant squid they had an ROV they
had a remote operated vehicle down there
and we saw we didn't see any giant squid
but we saw the massive jellies and it's
it's hugely active tons of seabirds and
yeah bear polar bear seals
yeah
your difference between the warmest
water at the bottom in the top is if
that four degrees where like water is
supposedly more denser is it much bigger
than that
yeah well that that's a very interesting
question the UM so the four degrees
relates to fresh water so now we have
salt in the water but but it's very
interesting because I keep talking about
warm and it's all red and it's well it's
it's only a degree above zero if that
but we we say it's warm because it's
it's fatal to Arctic sea ice because the
ocean freezes at about minus two degrees
Celsius so when I talk about warm layers
that are a degree Celsius they're not
warm enough to swim in like it's not you
know it's not like you know summertime
warm if you go down deep in the Arctic
no it's still really really cold but
relative to sea ice it's it's warm so
yeah thank you for pointing that out
because yeah yeah right you've just
asked the question that is the whole
basis of my research yeah so um this is
what we're trying to understand we see
in the we see these deep warm layers in
the Arctic getting warmer and warmer but
we don't see necessarily that heat
escaping to the surface at least not not
everywhere so we're trying to understand
what the limit is on how warm those
waters can get before we end up in some
kind of unstable situation or ultimately
what is the fate of that heat if it's
not escaping to the surface where is it
going so these are the time sorry I
don't have an answer for you but I will
work on some papers and yeah
yes yes so so um so there's not a
situation where you would have water of
the same salinity and differing
temperatures where you have warm water
on the bottom the only scenario where
you can get warm water on the bottom is
if that warm water is also saltier and
more dense than the cooler water above
yeah that's really interesting so the
the Arctic Ocean and the Southern Ocean
are different from the rest of the
world's oceans because they are
stratified by salinity and we've learned
that today as you get deeper it gets
saltier they're not stratified by
temperature the rest of the world's
oceans are stratified predominantly by
temperature as you get deeper it gets
colder sea ice can only grow over an
ocean that's stratified by salinity and
we're seeing a marching forward or a
marching northward of mid-latitude type
oceans encroaching into the Arctic so so
weather weather this I don't think it's
a tipping point but it's a transition in
the way the arctic ocean works as our as
our climate warms yeah so I so
springtime now I know the pond at my
house has got warmer water on the bottom
of the top yeah and it's gonna turn over
pretty soon in this this fresh water
right there they're parts of the ocean
that turn over that way
um not that I can think of off the top
of my head but but probably why not tell
us that that's happened right okay so
that that brings up an interesting point
so we have if you look on the back in
the long-term climate records the
climate fluctuates through all of these
different fluctuations and sometimes
it's it tends to fluctuate quite rapidly
and then the question is well what
caused that and actually some scientists
do have theories of this type of
overturning one relating to we know on
the on the seafloor
there's geothermal heat that there's oh
they're cooling of the Earth's crust is
always warming and it's always warming
the ocean it's like that you put the
ocean on a stove you know and it heats
from below and that's called geothermal
heating and so but it doesn't it doesn't
kind of turn over because it's saltier
but if you heat it enough all of a
sudden yeah it's gonna turn over so
there are scenarios like that where you
get this competing influences of
temperature and salt content and one can
win over the other say
yeah so why is the sea-ice important
well we saw that at the beginning when
we said sea-ice regulates the Earth's
climate because it reflects back a lot
of the incoming solar radiation and that
you know that that we need to keep our
to keep our earth at just the
temperature that the ecosystems and and
all of us have adapted to live on earth
so that's why it's that's one of the
main reasons why it's important of
course it's also important for wildlife
and Arctic ecosystems and indigenous
people who hunt and live up there off
the sea ice and so on
yeah great um so we know that there are
two types of major ice on our planet and
one of them is the sea ice that we
talked about today that you get when
there when the oceans freeze and the
other is what we call land ice which is
in glaciers and ice sheets
so when you see Greenland if you look at
Google Earth of Greenland its white and
there's you know it's it's covered in
ice and that ice is not the same as the
frozen sea water but that ice is there
because over thousands and millions of
years it's snowed and packed down snow
and packed down and made this this sort
of deep ice but it's sitting on land so
what's happening is as Greenland and
Antarctica as they melt as that as that
ice is sitting on land melt it goes into
the ocean and that increases the volume
of water in the ocean and so the oceans
rise that's one of the main reasons the
other main reason that we have sea-level
rise is because and here's some
intuition for you as you as you heat up
water it expands right so as the oceans
are heating up they're expanding and
therefore the sea levels are rising so
those are the two two main factors
[Music]
yeah so the main thing the main thing
that we can do so there are all kinds of
things that we can we can do to to help
our planet stay healthy
and that relates to you know reducing
plastics certainly not polluting and so
on but these sort of big picture
question that we're talking about today
this classic global warming as
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere rise
surface air temperatures rise air
temperatures rise the main greenhouse
gas offender is is co2 putting carbon
dioxide into the into the atmosphere and
that derives from burning fossil fuels
so the main thing that we could do is we
can stop burning fossil fuels and we can
implement policies to reduce our fossil
fuel emissions and anything else is just
sort of secondary yeah
yes that's a great idea
and there are all kinds of really
interesting nuts that's um that that's
along the lines of of this field of
geoengineering which is to try to to try
to change to try to change the Earth's
climate by taking co2 out of the
atmosphere somehow and planting forests
is one really good strategy stopping
cutting down forests is easier as well
there are all kinds of things that we
could be doing to limit co2 emissions
there and there are new technologies out
people are what you call scrubbing co2
out of stack where it's coming out and
extracting the co2 from the from the
effluent as it comes up the stack and
then you can use it you can make gyproc
and use it for all kinds of interesting
interesting things so it's all about
innovative solutions so this is this is
what all of you need to be thinking
about in the future
[Applause]
[Music]